all right so in Monday's lecture we
talked about how cells eventually of how
cells replicate okay and today I want to
talk about how now an entire organ would
essentially replicate in this case is
not going to divide but it's going to
regenerate or renew itself okay
and so this involves us adult stem cells
and also apoptosis which you've heard a
little bit about earlier in the course
and to explain this to you I'm gonna
have a basically a model organ that
we'll use and we'll use it for a couple
lectures and the model organ is going to
be the lining of the intestine okay so
the lining of the intestine is an
epithelial tissue and I'll tell you a
little bit about epithelia in just a
minute but you have the intestinal
epithelium and this is the these are the
cells that are the lining of the
intestine okay and they're one of the
reasons that I've chosen this system is
because the lining of your intestine has
pretty remarkable regenerative
capabilities okay so your small
intestine renews about every four to
five days okay so the vast majority of
your cells in the intestine were
basically derived in the last four to
five days okay so you know humans aren't
as cool is some organisms like newts and
that you can't like cut off your arm and
have it grow back but at least we have
the intestine which undergoes a pretty
dramatic regeneration okay and this is
not the intestine is unique in how rapid
this is but you have other tissues that
also exhibit
continual renewal like your skin in your
blood cells and even the cells of your
that line your the insides of your lungs
they do exhibit renewal capabilities
okay and so I'm going to use the
intestine as sort of a model system it
doesn't mean it doesn't happen in other
tissues but it just happens that we can
we really understand the intestine
system maybe a little bit more than many
other systems so I'm going to use it as
an example so in thinking about the
lining of your intestine it's important
and it has important functions one
important function of this lining is it
has to absorb nutrients from food going
through your intent going through your
intestine okay so it exhibits a nutrient
nutrient absorption function now the
lining of your intestine much like your
skin is also a barrier between the
inside of your body and the outside
world right because basically the the
inside of your intestine is contiguous
with the outside world right if you open
your mouth you you can get down to the
inside of your intestine okay so it
serves also an important barrier
function and one point I want to make
about this system right now is that the
intestinal epithelium like many of your
other organism organs are they're
composed of multiple cell types okay so
it also has multiple cell types
okay so let's now consider the lining of
the intestine and I'll the way the
intestine morphologically looks is that
there are a series of invaginations so
this is a cross-section view through the
intestine so you have to imagine that
this is a cross-section view but that
this is a plane and it's a plane with a
lot of invaginations in the plane but
also protrusions out of the plane and so
you have to remember you have to think
of this as a surface and then it's
wrapped up into a tube okay so this is
just a very simple cross-section image
of the intestine okay and it's the
lining of the intestine is a sheet of
cells so this lining is composed of many
many cells they're columnar and
morphology so what I've drawn here is
just a small section of the intestine
this would be the lumen out here this is
where the food is or the food going
through your intestine would be and then
below here this is sort of interstitial
fluid but inside of your body basically
interstitial okay so the foods up here
your the rest of your body is down here
and there you can see that there are
there's a structure to it it's not just
a flat surface that's wrapped up but
there are invaginations and the
imaginations are known as intestinal
crypts right much like you would you
know if you bury something like a body
it would go below ground so this is the
Crypt it's kind of below the surface of
the lumen and this these projections out
here
are known as villi so they're the the
villi of your gut okay now if we
consider in and this this lining is made
up of multiple cell types which I've
outlined up here and which are in your
handout so you don't have to write these
down but this is just making the point
that there are various differentiated
cell types there are entero sites which
are the absorptive cells these are the
cells that are taking in nutrients and
transporting them into your body
there are entero and endocrine cells
that play an important signaling
function in the gut to regulate the
biology of the gut system there are
goblet cells which secrete mucus into
the intestine system which protects
these epithelial cells from digestive
enzymes that are present in the lumen
and there's this last cell type the
Paneth cell which functions is an
important role in regulating stem cells
as I outlined in just a minute so these
are all the differentiated cell types
but there's a type of cell that's an
undifferentiated cell type and that's
the intestinal stem cell which will be
the hero of today's lecture all right
now if we consider just a small a group
of cells what these cells look like is
this okay so this is these are what are
known as epithelial cells and epithelial
cells have certain properties the first
is you see that this end of the
epithelial cell looks different from
this end okay and this is called an
apical basal polarity
so much like neurons have a polarity
where the on one side of the neuron
there are dendrites and on the other
side of the neuron there's an axon these
cells have another type of polarity
which is called apical basal polarity so
the side facing the lumen is apical so
the lumen would be up here and the basal
side would be down here okay so this is
basically oriented along this axis of
the tissue okay
we're a pickles on this side Basil's on
this side okay and the these projections
from an individual cell these are called
micro villi and essentially this these
plasma membrane corrugations increase
the surface area through which nutrients
can be absorbed into these cells okay
now one other defining feature of these
cells is they have proteins that
protrude from the plasma membrane and
these are adhesion proteins the couple
the cells together and actually the
cells are stuck together much tighter
than I'm drawing here such that the
cells form a barrier so that things
can't pass unregulated from the lumen
into the body okay but these these
proteins which I'm drawing sticking out
of the membranes of the cells are
adhesion proteins
and these adhesion proteins simply link
the cells together such that they form
as a sheet of cells or a tissue
so they link cells together okay so
these are two of the key properties of
epithelia they have an apical basal
polarity and they also exhibit cell to
cell adhesion such that the cells reach
out and and connect to each other and
they basically are glued together or
velcroed together such that they don't
easily come apart okay now in
considering this system what I'm going
to tell you is that there is renewal of
this lining and the renewal starts at
the base of the crimps okay so there's
going to be renewal and the cell renewal
is at the base of the crypts right there
are many of these crypts right you have
you have like the surface but there are
many many invaginations that are present
in your gut and and the renewal is
happening at the base of these crypts
okay
and that's because at the base of these
crypts are where a type of cell known as
intestinal stem cells lie okay so it's
at the base of these crypts where there
are what are known as intestinal stem
cells and I'm going to abbreviate these
is C's for this so I don't have to write
out intestinal stem cell whenever I tell
you about them okay now that's where
renewal occurs and if you just had knew
more and more cells getting put in the
system without any removal of cells then
the organ would get bigger and bigger
right and so our intestine is more or
less staying the same size at this point
in our life and so
in addition to renewal there's also cell
death and what happens when cell death
occurs is that cells are shed from the
intestinal lining into the lumen so
cells are shed into the lumen and then
they just go with the rest of the crap
that's in your intestinal lumen and it's
eventually removed from the body okay so
some cells are leaving the tissue and
going into the lumen after they've
existed for a few days in the intestine
okay so to have an organ then the
constant size renewal has to essentially
be more or less equal to death okay and
so you can think of this as a type of
homeostatic State for this tissue where
if renewal equals death you have what is
known as tissue homeostasis where the
number of cells in the system and as a
whole is basically remaining the same
even though there's constantly new cells
going into the system but then the cells
are also the older cells are being
removed from the system so what's really
key in this process are these intestinal
stem cells so I'm first going to tell
you about stem cells and these are what
I would define as adult stem cells
okay so there's stem cells that are
associated with a particular organ okay
and I want to differentiate this right
now between these types of stem cells
and another type of stem cell that we're
going to talk about later in the course
which is an embryonic stem cell
so adult stem cells these stem cells are
like intestinal stem cells are
associated with a specific organ and
they only give rise to cell types that
are present in that organ okay so
they're not they can't give rise to any
type of cell type your adult stem cells
a really specific organ specific will
say in contrast embryonic stem cells are
they can these stem cells have more
possibilities they can give rise to
pretty much any cell type in an entire
organism okay so you can think of these
adult stem cells as being more
restricted in their fates than the
embryonic stem cells and so what adult
stem cells are called is they're called
multipotent because they can give rise
to multiple different cell types but not
all of the cell types that are present
in an organism right an intestinal stem
cell will not be giving rise to a blood
cell or like other cell types in other
organs right it's restricted to just
giving rise to cells that are present in
that organ in contrast embryonic stem
cells are what are known as pody potent
or sometimes pluripotent where this type
of cell really is capable of making any
type of cell that is present in an adult
organism okay
so that's less restricted than the adult
stem cells and we're gonna come back to
these embryonic stem cells towards the
end of the course but for understanding
cancer and also tissue homeostasis in
the intestine we're really needing to
focus on the adult stem cells
okay so these adult stem cells have two
key properties the first is what I just
said they're multipotent and what
multipotent means is that they can give
rise to multiple different cell types so
these this stem cell gives rise to
multiple cell types and this is
associated usually with a single organ
system okay so in the case of the
intestinal stem cell the intestinal stem
cell is multi potent and it can give
rise to many different terminally
differentiated cells and you can see
here I just sort of written in example
cell types that the intestinal cell
could generate it can generate any of
the four different types of cells that I
introduced to you at the beginning of
the lecture okay the other key aspect of
this system is that in addition to
generating all of these different cell
types the stem cell can also renew
itself okay so the other key property is
this self renewal so the intestinal stem
cell also gives rise to another
intestinal stem cell so it basically
duplicates itself such that you still
have a stem cell in the organ and then
what one of the daughter cells is self
renewed and remains a stem cell the
other daughter cell can go on to divide
further and give rise to these
differentiated cell types okay
all right so one question you might be
asking yourself is how is it that what
regulates whether or not a cell will go
on to differentiate or whether it will
stay a stem cell and the answer to this
question involves communication between
the stem cell and other cells in the
system and it involves a special type of
cell called a stem cell niche cell and
so I'm going to tell you about a model
which is the stem cell niche model and
what the stem cell niche model is is
that basically there's a niche or
compartment which promotes the self
renewal of cells and that compartment it
makes them stem cells so the stem cell
niche you can think of as a compartment
where signals similar to the types of
signals that we've been talking about
over the past four or five lectures
regulate the behavior of the cell to
ensure self renewal in to suppress
differentiation so compartment where
signals promote stem cell renewal
oh I want to ask you one question
before I move on which is how how would
you define how would you determine that
there is a special type of cell that
gives rise to all of the cells in an
organ
how do if if you were tasked with the
finding this and determining whether
this was true or not how might you do it
does anyone have an idea of like what
experiment they would do or what
criteria they would have to determine
whether or not this is a case
let's say I gave you a cell right in
like a dish and I asked you to tell me
whether or not you would think this is a
stem cell or not yes miles so miles
suggested it he would like to take the
cell that I just gifted him and let it
grow up and determine whether it gives
rise to multiple cell types and Miles
said that if it just gave rise to a
single cell type that would suggest that
it's not a stem cell but if it gave give
rise to multiple cell types then it
could be a stem cell okay
and it's this type of experiment that
this type of experiment has been done
where you can take an intestine from
mice and even you can take tissue from
humans and you can dissociate the cells
from each other so that so that you're
left with single cells that are separate
and you can then use some type of flow
cytometry to separate cells and you
might be interested in a cell that maybe
expresses some marker that you're
interested in and you can separate those
cells and isolate them and then you can
take an individual cell and grow it in a
dish okay and this has been done for
intestinal stem cells and if you take an
intestinal stem cell and you grow it in
a dish it can grow up and form like a
bulk of tissue but what's really
remarkable about the result of this
experiment is that from a stem cell you
get this massive tissue but it self
organizes into a structure that very
much resembles a normal gut meaning that
there's there are crypts where there the
stem cells are localized
and then if you look at the different
cell types in this what's known as an
organ ID you see all of the different
cell types that are normally present in
the gut
okay and so this is an example of a type
of experiment that's done to show
whether or not a certain cell has the
capability of functioning like a stem
cell okay so if you start with a stem
cell you can regenerate the entire organ
system essentially you might also be
familiar with bone marrow transplants
and so if you kill all the hematopoietic
stem cells in let's say a mouse then you
can transplant in a single hematopoietic
stem cell into that system and it will
regenerate all the blood cells in that
sort of in that system okay so those are
just a few examples of how one might
functionally define a stem cell in an
experimental setting all right so now I
want to tell you about the types of
signals and how these signals are
promoting stem cell renewal okay so in
this case the niche the stem cell niche
is going to be right here and the types
of signals involved I'll just draw some
cells here one of the types of cells
that's part of the niche in the
intestine is the cell type that I
introduced you as the Paneth cell and
these Paneth cells localized to the base
of the crypts together with the
intestinal stem cells and what Paneth
cells do is they send a signal to
neighboring cells and this signal is a
wynt signal which I'll tell you about in
just a minute and so this is the
intestinal stem cell here and the panas
cell is signaling to that intestinal
stem cell through a secreted ligand
known as wint
so wint is a secreted ligand and this
signal is what's known as a juxtacrine
signal
which just means that the cells have to
be adjacent or juxtaposed to each other
in order for the sending cell to signal
to its neighbor okay so it's not
signaling long range but it's signaling
to a neighboring cell okay so now if we
think about this intestinal stem cell
one thing intestinal stem cells do is
they divide right so this intestinal
stem cell could divide here's a cell in
mitosis it rounds up and divides here
you still have your Paneth cell and then
when this cell divides then it's going
to be two cells okay so now pana cell
another cell here are the two daughter
cells here's the pan it's cell the penet
cell is still secreting this wynt signal
so you have wint getting secreted and
it's gonna signal to its neighbor but
this cell is starting to get farther and
farther away from that signal right so
you can imagine this is happening right
here and the tissue where this cell is
at the boundary of the niche okay so
this cell that gets pushed out of the
niche is going to start to differentiate
okay because it's it's no longer seeing
the signal okay so it's the lack of the
wind' signal which tells cells basically
that they should start differentiating
into the various cell types of the gut
but the cells that are stuck at the base
of the crypt down with the Paneth cells
are still getting the wynt signal and so
they remain an intestinal stem cell
okay so here's just a diagram showing
you part of that so the niche is down
here we are the stem cells the Paneth
cells would be some of these blue cells
at the base but there are also other
cells below the epithelial lining known
as stromal cells that are also secreting
wynt
and so this compartment down here has
high wynt ligand activity and that tells
cells that remain here to stay stem
cells but the cells that are getting
pushed up and moving up towards the
lumen they no longer receive this signal
and so they are going to start to
differentiate okay so you can think of
this system is almost a conveyor belt
there's a conveyor belt like movement of
cells from the base of the Crypt up
towards the tip of the villus okay and
when the cells move away from the niche
cells then they no longer have the self
renewal signal and therefore they go on
to differentiate okay go back for now
all right now I want to tell you a
little bit about this signal went
because there's something that's come up
before in the lecture even though you
might not know it so wynt
is a ligand so it functions much like a
growth factor this is something this is
a protein that is secreted from the cell
and then binds to receptors on other
cells and induces signaling events in
those cells okay and what wint stands
for the W W stands for wingless okay so
you remember from earlier and the
semester wingless is was identified as a
mutant that disrupts the formation of
wings in the fly okay so one of the
places where this genes where these
genes were discovered is in the fly the
end of wint
comes from int one
which stands for the integration of
mouse memory virus one sorry that's a
little bit more of a mouthful
integration of mouse actually sorry
mouse mammary tumor virus one
I forgot the tumor part of it okay so
the wool and wint is from wingless the
int and wint is from inch one okay
and so as you can see this there are two
different systems where these this type
of gene was discovered they're very
disparate from each other one was in a
developmental mutant in the fruit fly
the other was in a sort of a map system
where the integration of the virus
caused over expression of wint which
causes tumorigenesis okay so these
disparate systems led to that
identification of this wint molecule and
this is a defining member of a signaling
pathway that regulates stem cell renewal
and I just want to briefly go through
the logic of the signaling pathway
because I want you to get a sense that
not all signaling pathways are like
wrasse map kinase but there can be
different regulatory logic okay so
what's the regulatory logic of this
pathway so the regulatory logic is shown
in this cartoon and I'm going to start
with a cell that does not see wint
ligand so that would be the case on the
left here so if there's no wint ligand I
want to you to focus on what's going on
here there's a complex that's present in
the cytoplasm of the cell and what it's
doing is it's destroying this beta
catenin protein okay so what beta
catenin is
among other things it's a
transcriptional co-activator so it's
basically a transcription factor so it
works with another protein to regulate
the expression of certain genes okay and
and in the absence of wynt this beta
catenin transcription factor is
destroyed and is not able to get into
the nucleus okay
so if there's no wynt
then beta catenin is destroyed and it's
destroyed using a system that I
introduced in Monday's lecture which is
regulated pro dialysis by poly
ubiquitination okay so the first reals
so you have regulated proteolysis by
poly ubiquitination so the way this
works is xin here is that beta catenin
is bound by this complex and there's a
kinase the phosphorylates beta catenin
and then the phosphorylated beta catenin
recruits this e3 ubiquitin ligase which
poly ubiquitinated okay so that leads to
the destruction of beta catenin in the
absence of a win signal but when wint
ligand is around this leads to the
disassembly of this complex which is
known as the destruction complex and
that leads to beta catenin accumulating
and once it accumulates it goes into the
nucleus and starts changing gene
expression okay so in the presence of
wynt
beta-catenin is nuclear and that's where
it needs to be if it's going to regulate
gene expression okay so what you see is
this the logic of this pathway is you
have a double negative where you have a
complex which is known as the
destruction complex and it includes this
gene APC which we're going to talk about
on Friday this destruction complex is
inhibiting beta catenin by destroying it
and the way that wynt induces beta
catenin activation is by inhibiting the
inhibitor so wynt inhibits the
destruction complex which then
stabilizes beta catenin and allows it to
go to the nucleus okay so the other
piece of the logic here is you have
inhibition of an inhibitor to activate
beta catenin any questions on the
pathway
okay so now that we have now the the
this we have our intestinal stem cells
and we have a way by increasing wynt in
this compartment to maintain the
intestinal stem cells through self
renewal now we have to talk about the
the compensatory mechanism of death
which allows this tissue to maintain
homeostasis okay
so death in this case death is going to
be useful and the process of death is
called apoptosis and apoptosis is Greek
for falling off and that's essentially
what these cells are doing because the
cells as they move from the base of the
crypt up towards the lumen eventually
they're going to fall off into the lumen
of the intestine so again I'll draw
here's a villus this is now a villus
and so what happens is that the tip of
the villus cells are going to be shed
from the lining of the epithelium into
the lumen the lumens up here this is the
villus and this cells are going to shed
off into the lumen and be removed from
the organ system okay
so cells are shed into the lumen here
okay and this is going to balance the
renewal at the at the base of the crypts
such that there's homeostasis so I just
I the movie I was showing you at the
beginning of class was a movie showing
you what happens to a cell undergoing
apoptosis so in this case the cells by
nuclear and unhappy and that you're
gonna see they're basically explodes
okay so that's a cell undergoing
apoptosis but you see that there's a
clear change in cell morphology and
physiology associated with this and I
just want to point out that this is also
something that we talked about earlier
in the course and we talked about
experiments a genetic screen that led to
the identification of the pathway that
regulates apoptosis and that was done by
Robert Horvitz most a much of it was
done by Robert Horvitz in his lab here
at MIT and for that work Robert Horvitz
in addition to his colleagues won the
2000 2002 Nobel Prize so you'll recall
this is something we talked about in the
context of a genetic screen but this is
something that's this is what it's doing
in your intestine system it's balancing
renewal so that you have homeostasis so
during apoptosis a cell goes through a
series of changes first or what happens
eventually is the nucleus becomes
fragmented and the chromosomal DNA even
gets fragmented it gets chopped up and
also the nuclear plasma or the plasma
membrane also starts
and fragment such that it breaks up into
what are known as these epic tonic
bodies okay and so you can think of
these apoptotic bodies as bite-sized
pieces of cell that neighboring
phagocytic cells can eat up and remove
them from the body okay so in this case
the cells are being shed into the lumen
so they don't need to get eaten up
because they're just going to go out the
digestive tract
so there are new cells have numerous
ways to activate activate this apoptosis
process I'm going to tell you about two
types of signals that regulate whether
or not a cell undergoes apoptosis the
first is that there can be a signal that
basically tells the cell to kill itself
okay so you can think of this as a kill
signal and one type of way to activate
this signal is if the DNA is irreparably
damaged so if there's a high level of
DNA damage this induces a signaling
process in the cell and one of the
results of that signal in addition to
regulating the cell cycle if the DNA
damage is great enough it will induce an
apoptotic signal and it will activate
the pathway that the Horvitz lab
elucidated in the worm okay so there's a
signal and that leads to apoptosis and
death another type of signal that's
critically important for tissue
homeostasis in determining whether or
not cells live or die is a survival
signal so there are cell survival
signals and many of the the growth
factors such as EGF which you've heard
about in addition to inducing
proliferation these growth factors also
tell the cell not to die okay so these
could be growth factors
and what these cell survival signals do
is they repress apoptosis and so you can
think of it where you have a cell
constantly needs to be communicated to
and it needs to be told don't die don't
die don't die don't die and then if you
remove that signal it won't be getting
that information anymore and it can
undergo apoptosis okay so if we were to
remove this signal you remove the brakes
on apoptosis and the cell will undergo
cell death okay
so this is this is this ensures that you
don't have a cell just kind of like
going on and doing its own thing because
cells in order to live often need to
have some sort of signal from another
cell that tells them to live and so
there's some coordination between cells
such that you don't have cells rampantly
dividing out of control
now the reason we're doing this right
before we talk about cancer on Friday is
because everything that I'm telling you
is really essential to understand how a
tumor is formed in an organ system okay
and I want to end the lecture by just
planting a seed of an idea in your heads
before we move on to talk about cancer
on Friday and I want to I want you to
think about the organization of this
system where you have stem cells
undergoing renewal and then the stem
cells right are just a small fraction of
the cells in the system and they're
dividing slowly okay so let's think
about the stem cells the DNA on the stem
cells these are dividing slowly and
because they're dividing slowly they're
not going to their DNA is not going to
accumulate as many mutations so there's
going to be sort of fewer mutations but
these are the cells and this is the
genomic DNA that is going to stay with
the organ okay so the stem cells are
kind of like the crown jewels of the
organ the this is the material you want
the organ wants to protect because it's
what's going to be lasting in the organ
the entire lifetime of the organism okay
so you get slow division here and
self-renewal and these cell this cell
will stay with the organ but then where
most of the mitosis and cell division
happens and replication happens it leads
to a expansion of cells that all
differentiate and because the cells all
differentiate they will all eventually
die and get removed from the organ okay
and this is termed transient transit
amplification so when there's transit
amplification of one of the daughters of
this stem cell this is where there's
rapid division
and where there is rapid replication and
division this is where you can get the
most mutations but from the standpoint
of cancer that doesn't really matter
right because in order to have a tumor
the cells have to stay in the body and
so all of these cells are going to
undergo programmed cell death and then
be shed into the lumen of the intestine
and removed from the organism entirely
okay and so this is actually one
important way that our organs and our
bodies prevent tumors from happening
because the cell type that is going to
remain in our body is the one that's
protected from accumulating mutations
okay and we'll come back to this on
Friday and so I will see you on Friday
and we'll talk about cancer on Friday
you